l'association sogno tropicale est issu
d'une association qui est appelée à
croire et la double à 0 donc ça fait
plus de 15 ans que nous sommes pas que
moi je suis dans le milieu
la musique brésilienne de la danse
brésilienne et concrètement sous les
eaux tropicales ça fait six ans qu'on
fonctionne sous le nom de sony autour du
caire
[Musique]
objectif principal c'est de partager
partager la culture brésilienne le
folklore les danses
comida tickets repas tout ce qui est à
dire là l'origine qui se passe ce qui se
passe au brésil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce moment de l'année c'est un grand
honneur déjà pour nous un
représenter le brésil parce que
majoritairement du centre des
martiniquaises alors il y a plusieurs
années
confesse en martinique il ya des années
où nous n'étions pas là effectivement le
public nous a réclamé
l'année dernière nous étions à rio de
janeiro et cette année on a décidé avec
vous pour vous ramener justement les
chaleurs et les couleurs du brésil que
nous on est on est chargé à bloc on a vu
de belles choses et on a envie de vous
ramener tout ça alors on va vous montrer
tout ça déjà apparaître de saint pierre
ensuite nous serons sur plusieurs
soirées romantiques comme à l'accoutumée
et on espère amar charme confort de
france c'est toujours en négociation
on croise les doigts et
on essaie de vous donner de belles
choses à regarder vraiment partagé un
moment essentiel c'est le carnaval on
est là pour s'amuser
et rayonner voilà sept ans